صباح الخير
اعتقد انه
بدأت المقابلة
القيام بادرة تضامن
أو اللاعب البرازيلي
شاب أسود يلعب لريال مدريد
بالأمس في اللعبة
في ملعب فالنسيا كان
هاجم بشدة يتم استدعاؤه
قرد
وهذا هو ، ليس من الممكن أن لا تقريبا في
منتصف القرن الحادي والعشرين لدينا
قراءة التحيز العنصري في القوة في عدة
كرة القدم تنص هنا في أوروبا
ليس من العدل أن يكون الفتى المسكين
ربح في الحياة التي تتحول
ربما يكون أحد أفضل اللاعبين
من العالم بالتأكيد ريال مدريد هو
الأفضل هو الإساءة في كل دولة
إنه يحضر
أعتقد أنه من المهم أن يقوم FIFA بذلك
الدوري الاسباني هو عصبة الاخرين
بلدان بروفيدانس نصفي الكرة الأرضية
لأننا لا نستطيع السماح لـ
الفاشية تترسخ والعنصرية بداخلها
الدولة